dea
気になる日本語 episode 1ダイエットと逆ダイエットまず英語の定義を見て
みましょう
スペシャルフォース future me スティックスポンサーフィット to do
オックスフォード英語辞典次は日本語の底健康や美容のために食事の量や種類を制限
することスーパー大辞林から意味はほぼ同じです
簡潔に言うと健康のためにものを制限するということですまたあのなダイエットトマト
ジュースダイエット日本語でも英語でもこういう使い方がありますねこの例を見て違和
感を感じる日本人はまずいないと思います僕もそうですしかし最近はいいかながら使い
方もよく目にしますひねり運動7秒ダイエット1日13秒立つだけでダイエット
ロング
ブレスダイエットさらにこんなものも肩甲骨ダイエット最強の7分間仙骨台と大腰筋
ダイエットあーこれらの共通点は何でしょう
そうどれも即時に関係がないのです
上記はすべて痩せる方法でダイエットではないダイエットをつけてしまうと大腰筋
ダイエットなんかが健康や美容のために大腰筋を食べるって言うことになってしまい
ますまあ言語っていうのは常に進化しているからね多くの人はそういうでしょうけれど
忘れてはいけませんいくら日本が独り歩きをしても元の英語はまったく変わっていない
のです今度アメリカに留学するあなたよく聞いてください1年間アメリカに留学すると
あなたは半年で6キロ太りますそしてどうしよう
このままじゃあ日本に帰れないわっあと23か月を笑ってごまかした10か月目に入っ
てリアルに強くなり母
それから二週間後にやっとダイエットを始める気を付けて下さい
その後
ki まんだバックます緒絶なんてセリアに行っても全く意味が伝わりませんそれ
どころか羊たちの沈黙に出てきたのレクター博士に太った親戚じゃないかと思われて
しまいます続いてキャー
英語のギャングには猿轡や開口器という意味があるのをご存じですか実は google
で画像検索してみるとギャグとエッセン口
プレイでは結果がほとんど変わりませんギャグでは金髪女性の数が比較的に多いですが
もちろんギャグにを冗談や面白い仕草という意味もあるのですが辞書に最初に出てくる
のもそしてネイティブのはたまに最初に浮かぶの間違いなく5
もうフェチの方なんですですから終わらないすギャグなんて言ったらまたレクター博士
の話に乗ってしまう可能性があるのは否定できません文脈によって多くの場合は通じる
と思いますが
ジョークを使った桜が無難でしょうさもなければ気付かないうちに1クエ留学生になっ
ているかもしれん
ええええええ
rar